je pense que on est fondé à parler de
science même si notre science est encore
active débutante balbutiante et cetera
il ya malgré tout une séparation de
nature entre l'effort scientifique fait
l'historien l'ethnologue sociologue ou
l'économiste
est ce que fait par exemple le
philosophe nous nous nous nous
travaillons à être vérifiable
falsifiable je peux évoquer c'était une
expérience radiophonique un jour que je
venais disputes étaient d'ailleurs là
avec les villes boyer bon je vais
discuter son dernier livre sur le
patronat je venais d'écrire un article
sur le patronat il est arrivé je
m'appelle plus terreur antennes ou in
bon et il m'a dit vous savez mon cher
collègue j'ai regardé votre enquête j'ai
pris vos chiffres j'ai refait les
statistiques et nous ne sommes pas
d'accord j'y mais comment est-ce
possible
comment avez vous fait à oui mes amis je
n'ai pas l trophy les bandes qui habille
voilà c'est la cause est bon alors là
nous avons discuté sur la construction
d'objets c'est à dire est-ce qu'on peut
tuer le patronat sans s'y introduire les
banquiers c'est une problème de tout à
fait de discussion scientifique et cela
étant dit ils pouvaient refaire ses
statistiques et retrouver le résultat
que moi voilà le genre de chose qui me
semble-t-il me permettent de parler de
science étant entendu que quand je dis
science jeudi qu' on peut me réfuté les
arguments scientifiques mais juste à
présente encore à faire ça j'allais j'en
profite pour dire ça parce que j'y tiens
beaucoup
jusqu'à présent j'étais l'objet
d'attaqués jamais de réfutation au sens
rigoureux du terme je dirais que mon une
des raisons de ma tristesse enfin c'est
que dans le champ intellectuel français
j'ai beaucoup d'ennemis mais je n'ai pas
d'adversaire c'est à dire des gens qui
ferait le travail nécessaire pour
opposer une réputation alors je sais que
avatar on me répond mais ça c'est
totalitaire puisque vous êtes
irréfutable pas du tout pour me réfuté
il faut se lever de bonne heure il faut
travailler